it's nice when things get better so I
did reviews four seasons 1 and season 2
of orphan black why not come back into
the third one and you probably guess
from the intro like this so much better
than season two I had so many problems
with season two it was really kind of
ridiculous but this season way better I
actually think I like this one better
than season one and that's about all I
can say before i get into spoilers so
that's your spoiler free portion of the
review and i'm just gonna be jumping all
over in terms of what i talked about
with zero regard for spoilers so Sarah
got back to my good graces by doing the
smartest thing she should have possibly
done getting Kara away from all of this
I understand she's your kitty you want
to stay close to her but that should
have been done a while ago it's not like
I don't like Kira she's not as annoying
as young characters often are on these
things but just logistically get her out
of there so I'm glad that was done
Hellena I liked a lot this season and
and I she had grown on me last season
this time I really like her a lot
because you know we get like okay she's
kind of on the good guys side but she is
still crazy and she is still dangerous I
really like that they haven't defanged
her Allison still doing great for me
Donnie I'm really liking to the two of
them together are just a lot of fun
honestly they could kind of be their own
show and actually in a way they almost
are because their storyline actually
intersected very rarely with the rest of
the show and normally that would annoy
me because it'd be would be like well
you're using that as filler except that
she's so good and he's so good and the
two of them trying to bumble there who I
he threw becoming drug lords and sort of
the things that they're able to knuckle
down again the other stuff that they're
just yo your sewing over your head was
actually really fun and interesting so
even though it did not completely tie
back into everything else and that
should have bugged me it didn't cause it
was such an interesting story anyways
and that really is what makes the
difference cuz by designed this should
drive me nuts but you do it right and I
don't care you know who I was really
i buy this season Delphine I've actually
really enjoyed watching her develop as a
character and go from this kind of
generic I didn't care love interest for
Cosima into a character that I don't
know if I can trust but like she's not
she didn't just replace Rachel and
become the new Rachel but she's clearly
got her own thing going on and she's
still embedded in this group that we
know is dangerous and actually since I
mentioned Rachel I really like what they
did with Rachel because I was expected
given what happened to her at the lat
end of last season and she was just
gonna show up with an eye patch just as
angry and badass as she always was I'm
like that there was real impact or what
happened to her she has to go through
recovery she's kind of out of the game a
little bit the scene with her in Felix
and he's threatening her all what an
epic scene that was I'm probably not
gonna mention Felix again so I'll just
throw out there now he was good he
always is mrs. s was good always has
been ferdinand i really like he finally
they got a character who works because
he's kind of coming in and he's a little
bit sort of filling the the kind of
intimidating guy that Olivier was
supposed to be in the first season and
Daniel was supposed to be in the second
season and neither of them were really
worked at all he's good and I like
Minnie's fun Paul you know I was up and
down on him throughout the show up to
this point but you know what he went out
like a boss what an awesome way to close
out that character and close out his
story just really satisfying for me as a
viewer so yeah overall really good stuff
there are a couple of nitpicks those
still of varying degrees there's the
casters and I think how to ride neutral
for me they're not bad they're certainly
better than the proletheans were dear
God I never really got overly invested
in them the woman who is heading them up
was functional Cosima is annoying me
that she still I real I really wish you
would have just died at the end of
season two and and it really irritates
me that they got her and do another
relationship right off the bat because
on the show she has three functions to
be geeky to be sick and to be gay heaven
forbid we don't have her in a
relationship with a woman or pining
over a woman because then we might
actually have to deeper the character
come up with something meaningful and
new for her to do no no get her dating
again they were at this point they
really should just write out art because
they have not found anything for him to
do second season this season look to
either write him out completely or at
least just sort of take him off the
board for the time being and bring him
back when you actually have something
for him to do overall though this was a
really wonderful season and it almost
made it all the way to the end without
doing one really stupid thing but then
right at the finish line at tripped what
is that really stupid thing the donor
for the original DNA template for both
Leda and castor is mrs. esas mother what
I mean are there only 15 people on the
planet and they all have to be related
this this is ridiculous is this woman
we've never met never heard a reference
to its literally sheer dumb coincidence
that it happens to me mrs. as his mother
now that said they take the curse off it
slightly by introducing the idea that
she is the daughter for both the male
and female strands that is quite
interesting again has nothing to do with
the fact that she's mrs. as his mother
that has no bearing on anything you
counted this really stupid idea with an
interesting one and well it didn't quite
make up the ground it helped so that's
it over black season 3 i'm very much
looking forward to season 4 i'm not
going to make any promise that i'll do
episode by episode reviews it's a
possibility though i'm considering it
we'll see what happens in any case
orphan black season 3 have you seen it
have you seen all three seasons which
one is your favorite so far three I
think does clock in is my own personal
favorite but whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it please go ahead and
like subscribe follow me on Twitter at
Council of geeks and check out the
Council of geeks podcast on iTunes and
stitcher until next time this council is
adjourned